So what does recognition entail?
Well it's actually many different tasks.
One example is somebody might show
you a particular area and say,
you know, is that a lamp?
Okay, and that's verification.
And the, this particular case what
I mean is that it's verification of
a general class.
Okay?
Is this thing a lamp?
We'll get to identification in a minute.
Another possibility is you might say,
are there any people here?
And that would be detection.
That is, I haven't told you
where in the image to look,
I just want to know are there
any people in this scene.
Another is,
I might have a specific instance.
And I might show you an example,
and say is that Potala Palace?
That's in this particular case,
of a location, of a thing.
Sometimes, identification,
we all know, is in faces, right?
I show you and say,
you know, is this Megan?
And you say, no,
that's not nearly as nice as Megan.
But anyway, that's identification.
A more interesting question is what
we'll loosely call categorization,
all right?
So you're generally putting out a label.
You know, here we have this label that
in the background there are mountains,
and there's trees over here,
there's people here, vendors, this thing
was a street lamp, these are buildings.
And this is what's referred to
as object categorization and
we're going to talk more about that.
But we might also want to
just label the entire scene.
Say you know, this is an outdoor
city where people go and buy stuff.
All right, so that was also,
would entail some form of recognition.